this is a production of Cornell
University
all right so the students out there when
you're practicing your seminars is it's
for moments like this when you have to
do performance under pressure when oh
six of your slides got chewed up by your
PC or my flash drive or something so I'm
going to do my best to fill in those
gaps but hopefully it won't be too
serious sorry well the first thing I
want to do is thank people who did the
work towards the end but people who
funded the work long-standing funding to
my lab from the Department of Energy
both to my lab and then through this PFR
see that we have a Purdue called c3 bio
postdoctoral support for Pell by Nick
Bono it's from the LS RF and we've also
had funding from G SEPA funding agency
through Stanford NSF and our
collaborator John Ralph in the glbrc so
what I want to talk to you about today
is what I think is I I just testimony
how fortunate I am that we did a mutant
screen many years ago I discussed the
first of the mutants that came out of
that screen when I interviewed at vice
Thompson in 1993 I got the job at Purdue
though which is where I met my wife so
that's okay everything worked out just
fine
but it's a mutant scream that we started
and it took us down the road of enzymes
of phenylpropanolamine biosynthesis but
more recently we with this screen we
identified an important regulator
regulatory component a part of the
mediator complex which is why I sort of
have this oblique pun in here about
mediate that turns out to the function
of which turns out to explain a number
of the unexpected phenotypes we saw in
our biochemical mutants so you know I
thought it's going to be a little bit
weaving and crossing over that I hope I
can can walk you through all this so
first of all why are we interested in
studying tunnel propanol metabolism I've
had a long interest in secondary
Tabassum why plants make all the
fabulous compounds that they make but
some approximate metabolism was one is
particularly important both biologically
and in terms of the use of biomass for
humans for bioenergy or animal feed or
even for paper production but it's for
plants it was one of the important
innovations that permitted the
colonization of land because it involves
the generation of molecules that comes
our beauty light that the plants now
have two times that now have to deal
with if they're on land compared to
living in an aquatic environment so this
happens to be the molecule that's going
to feature prominently in this talk it's
a UV protected molecule that a rapid
Ossus makes called cinebulle malate and
of course this portion of the molecule
on the right that is responsible for
absorbing UV and the reason that I show
this portion of the knee in in blue is
that the great feature about this for us
is that it this this moiety makes this
molecule fluorescent under UV light so
as a mutant phenotype the presence or
absence of this fluorescent has
fluorescence has been very useful to us
the other important component that is
derive from this pathway is lignin and
this is sort of a schematic
representation of what Lincoln might
look like it's we don't still don't have
a very good understanding of the actual
structural well we know the structural
motifs but not exactly how it exists in
the wall and of course this is this
molecule I like to describe it as being
important at both the macroscopic and
microscopic level so that the lignin
polymers impress is pregnant into the
cell wall where it gives it rigidity and
allows these trees to stand upright and
withstand the forces of wind and what
have you so it's a very important at
that level but at the microscopic level
it's also important
as as a molecule that strengthens the
cell walls of water conducting tissue
does Island so here's a cross section of
a rabbit ops system and you can see the
trachea elements that are nice and big
and open and good for conducting water
and in this mutant that has lower levels
of lignin those same cells have
collapsed under the tension of course
that's developed by transpiration now I
don't want to leave you with the
impression that lignin - the only
important strengthening agent a
cellulose deficient mutant will show a
similar phenotype so it's clearly a
codependent Network so anyhow it's
pretty clear that these this pathway is
very important now for as well
many of you probably aren't lignin
experts but have heard a lot about it
and with regard to to biomass and
biofuel production why is that well one
of the reasons I would argue is that it
is a it is it represents low-hanging
fruit it's a unique polymer in that
let's go through the other ones that
we're all familiar with them in plants
or in organisms nucleic acids we know
that their synthesis is template
dependent protein synthesis we're
reading an mRNA template to make a
protein molecule polysaccharides well
it's a little bit different but at least
it's but still there's other specific
enzymes that make specific linkages to
make very characteristic polysaccharides
in a cell wall lignin synthesis is
entirely different in that it's the
types of cross links that you see in the
lignin polymer and the components that
make it up are dependent only upon the
precursor supply so whatever whatever so
called mono leg knows that a plant makes
whatever ratio that they the client
makes them in is represented in what
what the polymer is like now it let's
just contrast that if you made it had a
yeast cell that overproduced leucine you
would never expect to see its proteins
containing more losing but here we can
we have found and I'll show you some of
the data are really data picture
that we have that show that we can
manipulate monolid no synthesis and
thereby manipulate pre uh bleedin both
chemistry and it turns out architecture
so ligand mono lignin biosynthesis
begins in the cytoplasm with amino acid
phenylalanine and there's a series of
hydroxylation and methylation reactions
that lead to these three alcohols para
cumin or alcohol canal qahal and cynical
alcohol so called H G and s sub units
for lignin and so you can see that what
we're talking about is differences in
the decoration of the ring so this is
the earliest branch of the pathway the
second one in the third round and I'll
show this slightly differently in some
upcoming slides so these molecules can
then be exported to the apple plast
where they're activated to their two
free radicals by Lac cases and
peroxidases which then spontaneously
polymerize to form the polymer so
depending upon what monolid nulls are
made that that determines what comes out
and what is polymerized
so here's a a representation of the
pathway that probably is sufficient for
most people's purposes it I assure you I
know the structures involved but if I
showed them all you wouldn't be able to
see them and you wouldn't remember them
anyway so I I don't know maybe it's
teaching twenty years of undergraduate
biochemistry that's driven me to this
but so this is my schematic of the
pathway and it again starts with
phenylalanine and give branches to give
the G subunit canaveral alcohol the S
sub units in apoyo al qahal I want to
show this because this molecule I
mentioned earlier is a derivative of
this same pathway so sin upon malli
comes off of the pathway fairly late so
by looking for mutants that are
deficient or reduced in sin upon mallet
accumulation we have been able to
identify enzymes and genes and enzymes
that are not only required for these
final transformations but
also a number of the steps that are
common to both sin upon Aly biosynthesis
and lignin biosynthesis and so what what
you'll go through my talk I'll often use
the accumulation of simple malli
basically as a proxy or overall activity
of this pathway so as I mentioned
Singapore malate is fluorescent blue
under UV light and you can actually see
that in planta and so here is a wild
type plant photograph just with a
transilluminator for illumination and
the first means we identified that we
called fall one for freulich acid
hydroxylase is it completely lacks in
Nepal malate and you can see it has this
nice red fluorescence it comes about
because well first there's no blue
fluorescence from cinebulle Maui but
also because some formality is as
effective UV sunscreen in its absence
that UV can penetrate down into the
mesophyll excited chlorophyll molecules
and you see chlorophyll fluorescence so
if we were to take this photograph again
with a yellow filter over the lens that
would block out this blue fluorescence
what you would see here is a red plant
and a plant that's basically just dark
because this is an effective sunscreen
of blocks UV from getting into the maze
ozone so what I want to talk what I'm
going to talk to you about today is a
number of these mutants the later ones
of which we refer to as ref for reduced
epidermal fluorescence all right so I
mentioned that we can manipulate lignin
biosynthesis and I mentioned that
partially in terms of the justification
for the research but but also it's
important for what we what's going to
come later in my talk so this is very
old work so I'm just going to mention it
very briefly so if we eliminate f5h very
light five hydroxyl aids in the file one
mutant this is the first time that we
had shown that we could do this lignin
manipulation so in the absence of that
enzyme
the lignin is derived entirely from G
subunits and the effect on the plant is
since there is no effect these plants
grow and develop normally
and that's perhaps not surprising
because if you look at outside pine
trees gymnosperms make only this g
lignin so we already know that's an
effective polymer in some in some plants
and so these are what evidences points
are are fine with that
in fact we've also found that if you
overexpress this step we can redirect
redirect flux over to make a pure s
lignin and again it has no effect on the
plants its and if it's a functional
lignin it's quite interesting because
it's easier to degrade and it actually
has instead of being a cross-linked
polymer it's a linear polymer so we're
really dramatically changing the cell
wall structure but the play it's
tolerated very well now that's not
always the case so we have another an
example of a mutant that is very early
in the pathway c3 primate and when we
block that step so the plants make a
lignin that is derived from these h
subunits this d subunits make up
normally about 1 percent of the the
polymer in a wild-type plant but the
lignin in these plants is almost
entirely derived from that but that has
very severe consequences so that's what
that plant looks like and so we were not
may be entirely surprised by this in the
lignin literature it was said that that
you couldn't even make h lignin and so
we thought well this is probably not a
functional polymer for some reason or
another so so the fact that that these
plants are dwarfed perhaps it's got to
do with and I'll just use the same slide
as I used earlier this idea that the
abundance of lignin is important those
plants make very little H lignin and
also show this vascular collapse and we
know obviously that that water transport
is very important to plant so a plant
that can't transport water just dwarf
not not a not a terribly big surprise
of course is a different thickness cell
type-specific yes in many cases so the
xylem has predominantly G lignin and
that's both in Arabidopsis and also in
tree species whereas supporting tissues
fibers clarified cells of deposit
esslingen but usually especially in the
case of those cells it's when I say s
legging it's really a GS copolymer so
the that is for your question
yep so I'm going to set that mutant down
for a moment and and talk about another
of the mutants that we worked on that
we've worked on called rf4 this turns
out to be the regulatory protein that I
that I mentioned at the beginning of my
talk although when we first identified
it we didn't understand that to be the
case so rf4 mutants also deposit Leslie
Linden wild-type so you're getting used
to seeing these now you can see that in
the strong allele we have collabs eylem
compared to these cells and we have
about a 25% reduction in overall lignin
content and that's highly consistent
with the literature that's about the
extent to which you can reduce lignin
before you start seeing phenotypes like
this these plants are also dwarfed you
can see here on on the right that so
this is the strong allele but once of
course we could call the gene we could
identify knockouts for this to see
whether they would recapitulate this
mutant phenotype and this is a knockout
for effort and you can see that it does
not this this is actually a missense
mutation that is semi dominant so it
wasn't really a huge surprise that the
knockout didn't recapitulate that
phenotype rf4 has a paralog in the
rabbit offices genome that we call ref
for related one or RFR one a knockout of
this also doesn't phenocopy ref for
three and the double
Macha also does not so there's certainly
something special about this particular
mutant allele with this it's a very
minor change in the protein structure
it's a glycine to serine alterations but
what it appears is that that mutation
causes that protein to act as a
constitutive break on phenol propria
metabolism so we were very relieved in
fact to find that the double knock the
knockouts or the double knock go
particularly gives the opposite
phenotype so here's a wild-type this is
using again cinema male levels as a
measure of phenol propanol you knockout
ref for there's really no change you
knockout are 4-1 you do get an increase
in the double knockout has an even more
substantial increase so the fact that
this is a great relief because the fact
that this gives the opposite phenotype
to this suggests that this is not a neo
morphic mutation so this is actually a
protein that's acting in the same
pathway it normally acted so again for
the students if you've not thought about
this before if you think about a neo
morphing tation what about a
transcription factor that has a missense
mutation that leads to a change in the
amino acids on the DNA binding domain so
now allow it to bind somewhere where it
wouldn't normally bind now you start
studying that now you're studying a
context for that transcription factor
that's not biologically relevant so here
the knock out of having the opposite
phenotype to the to this dominant
mutation was was a great relief to us
okay so what is what is rf4 well we
didn't know for the longest time it has
it's found in all plants it has no
domains that allow you to might you
there's no ATP's I mean it doesn't even
have a domain of unknown function and so
we were actually left scratching our
head for the longest time about what
this thing is really doing until
somebody purified the mediator complex
from Arabidopsis and rf4
immunoprecipitated with the rest of the
complex so what what is mediator it's a
large 30 protein transcriptional
regulatory complex that can associate
with another another kinase module and
bring in an yet another for proteins and
what it does is that it's it's divided
into a number of modules and this
so-called tail module interacts with
transcription factors bound to DNA both
locally and added at a distance and when
it does so the head and middle module
can recruit to the transcription start
site the the general transcriptional
machinery and so in doing so by making
contacts with a number of transcription
factors bound upstream of genes it can
generate a again can sort of interpret
that information and lead to a court
coordinated transcriptional output so
what we had identified was med 5 a youth
subunit of the tail this is really
fairly fanciful but the if you look at
the e/m reconstructions of it they're a
little bit hard to interpret so in some
ways the schematic is more useful but
anyway meds med 5 is the protein that
we've been looking at so we now have we
understand now that we've got a protein
that's involved in phenol appropriate
regulation we have a missense allele
that that suppresses some appropriate
gene expression and now for reasons that
are well entirely serendipitous my lab
we were making multiple means my postdoc
was and we can now circle back to this
rf8 mutant that I mentioned earlier that
was blocked earlier in the pathway and
made only H lignin we made a double NIC
made a triple mutant in fact between rf8
this very sad plant and this knockout of
these two flavors of this mid 5
mediators
unit and found that these plants were
capable of growing again which was a big
surprise because we thought well this is
all just to do with with malformed
lignin and lack of ability to transport
water but these plants grow just fine so
that was that was quite a puzzle to us
but it was very exciting what we found
was but Nick sound was that that was
actually able to restore lignin
deposition so again this is a measure of
lignin content you can see in the dwarf
bean that's very much suppressed but in
when we bring in the mediator mutations
that lignin content goes back up so
maybe it is the fact that the case that
these plants can transport water
properly they certainly look like they
can but also the it's not the case that
we had in any way restored normal
phenylpropanolamine sites are still
blocked at the same place we thought
that they were blocked before and what
we could really see where we could
really see that clearly was by doing the
lignin analysis and this has worked on
an John Ralph slab by Yuki Tohmatsu and
if you were if you were like really
interested in lignin you'd look at this
and go wow but you're not so let me
explain why you should be excited about
it so this is 2d NMR and lignin analysis
and the blue stands for the G subunits
the green for the s subunits and these
red residences here are for these eight
subunits that are normally just very
very minor components and so this plant
these plants that are growing normally
are making this this type of lignin that
people thought you plants couldn't make
so that we thought was pretty exciting
so now we've actually what I've
introduced along the way are to you our
plants that make two GS copolymer that's
the wild type pure g pure s and now pure
h Cygnet so you can see how this this
polymer can be very readily manipulated
anyway very for those questions in the
lignin community that was pretty pretty
exciting
so why why are these why is this meaning
to mutation restoring growth while we
bottom line is that we still don't know
but I can tell you a couple things that
aren't going on first of all it's not
the case that the low lignin is because
subtle gene expression is federal
procurement gene expression for lignin
synthesis is down regulated in the plant
because in fact in the ref a mutant is
up regulated all of these genes required
for lignin synthesis are up regulated in
the mutant and they are further up
regulated in in when we knock out the
mediator subunit so it's not that we're
restoring overall gene expression it's
certainly something more complicated
than that to try and get a handle on
that we did an rna-seq experiment and
what you can see is that well there's a
number of things I guess I should point
out so the on the left or the up
regulated genes on the right or the down
regulated genes and we're comparing the
mediator subunit double knockout the
lignin mutant and then the triple mutant
from boats so there's a few things one
is there's a huge number of genes that
are miss regulated in that that vary for
plant that's probably to be expected in
a plant that is so developmentally
perturbed there are relatively few genes
that are altered and expression when you
knock out this mediator subpoena which
and we're continuing to study this in
love how what what is the impact of
altering mediator on gene expression and
in many cases it's surprisingly modest
for an important what we what we always
consider to be an important component of
this transcriptional regulatory
apparatus and in the triple mutant
almost all of the genes over 90 percent
of the genes that are Mis regulated in
the mutant are returned to normal okay
so before I go to that so again we
haven't we still haven't identified the
actual cause from all of these there's
too big a number of genes to be able to
in on on what the actual cause of that
dwarfing is but we're almost inclined at
this point to say that it's not that
it's not that the low lignin causes the
dwarfing but perhaps it's the other way
around that we're actually altering
metabolism in such a way that we get
this massive transcriptional response
that is mediate or dependent so that's a
sort of a theme that I'll cure through
the rest of the talk that that perhaps
in these plants some metabolite is being
detected that accumulates because of the
the block in lignin biosynthesis and
that leads to mediate or dependent
changes in gene expression okay so now
I'm going to go on to my next sort of
case of a little vignette about mediator
and how it may function in regulating
metabolism both within pathways in
between pathways so this is not an
experiment it's a an anecdote it comes
from when I was a postdoc so in the
early 1990s before some of you were born
probably and it was when I originally
identified the hall one mutant so this
is the one that makes the pure G lignin
and what you can see here is two pots of
two there's two different alleles of
file1 that and wild-type I had been
growing these plants under in a nice
growth chamber and I
I needed the space for something else so
I moved the plants to someplace I don't
remember I think it was higher light and
a bit warmer temperature and the wild
type plants did what wild type plants
are prone to do and they were upset with
being moved and so they accumulated a
lot of anthocyanins commonly thought of
as being stress metabolites and yet the
fall one means did not do that and I was
really perplexed for that about that for
about 25 years
and we decided to try and follow up on
that a little bit you can become maybe
people in the front row can see your
many of you who have worked for the
rabid OPS's know that that rabid OPS's
petioles and stems this is a little bit
of anthocyanin there that's missing in
these fall one plans to try and get a
clearer signal we look use this this
line called pap on D in which which is
an activation tag line that turns on
expression of a transcription factor
which is a master regulator of
anthocyanin production and you can see
there's very dark red pigmentation in
the petals just it drives up the levels
that are not where they are normally
found but when you do when you cross
that into a file one background that
doesn't happen you don't get that level
of anthocyanin accumulation and this was
really perplexing to me oh yes I can
show you this again in cross-sections of
stems where you again get a lot of
anthocyanin accumulation of Papp 1d but
in a fall one path one d-double you fail
to get anthocyanin accumulation in all
the cells that would normally Express
that that gene so it seems that there's
clear that there's some interaction here
but the perplexing thing about this is
that this enzyme of fennel propyl ISM is
not required for for the production of
anthocyanins the anthocyanins branch out
very early from the pathway the enseña
poly and s lignin very late and yet
we're seeing this interaction between
these the accumulation of these products
that was very perplexing and we can see
that if we want to do if we did HPLC
analysis of those anthocyanins in
wild-type there's a large peak of
a couple of large peaks of anthocyanins
but when we measure by HPLC the red line
represents the levels of anthocyanins in
the following units very very low but
when we compare Med 5 the Med 5 mutant
we see anthocyanins just like in
wild-type but when we combine Med 5 a B
and file1 we restore anthocyanin
accumulation in this case it's a little
bit complicated it's a different
anthocyanin that accumulates because
this anthocyanin actually has a synaptic
acid subunit on it so that decoration is
missing and so we get a different
emphasize here but when I say f5h isn't
required for anthocyanin accumulation I
mean the core of the anthocyanins not
the decoration so this effect of fall
one on the suppression of anthocyanin
accumulation is mediator dependent what
we think is happening and I'll show off
show some models a little bit later is
again I mean perhaps a metabolite
upstream of that 5h is being sensed and
by an immediate or dependent way and is
shutting down from a proton metabolism
um ok this is I think where yes this is
where I go into the part of the talk
where my slides got corrupted so I'll
I'll do my best
the next meet and I want to tell you
about is this Beaton called R f2 and
another one that isn't shown in this
slide ref five for those of you who were
here when my postdoc interviewed dr.
Jung Yun Kim this is the story that she
told so perhaps you'll be able to fill
in the gaps that that are missing in my
slides so these two mutants rf2 and
refine are low incentive poem ally as
that UV phenotype reveals and we can
show that by HPLC as well so again
sinop O'Malley content and then these
multiple R f2 alleles it's suppressed
we've shown a long time ago this is from
2003 that rf2 encodes a cytochrome p450
dependent mono oxygenase known as sip 83
a 1 now the confusing thing at the time
was that these these p450 mono oxygenase
--is our hydroxylase is by and large but
all the hydroxyl lasers of an
appropriately pathway have been
accounted for by that time it turns out
that this p450 functions in a different
pathway let me go back watch this this
letter here ref 5 includes the pic
encodes the para log of rf2 and that sip
83 b1 I'm sorry I'm missing data off
this side so I can't show you the simple
malate levels but this is worth the
jugging published in 2015 now this is
where I have to do like interpretive
dance or something instead of showing
you the pathways but both of these
enzymes function in glucosinolate
metabolism most of you are probably
familiar with Lukas and lights yes but
for those who have not at least you have
if you like wasabi for example because
it's the horseradish or mustard those
those books only degradation products
that give those compound products their
flavor so sip 83 a1 and sip a t3 d1 are
enzymes of glucose in light biosynthesis
and yet a distinct pathway from tunnel
appropriate AB ilysm distinct you can
see on the right is distinct from the
pathway on the left it isn't there
anymore and yet it these blockages at
these point at these enzymes are
affecting subtle programs have ilysm
what Jonghyun went on to show was that
so this is a more in-depth analysis of
this rf5 mutant what she showed was that
if you if she blocked in the rf5 mutant
baby 3 B 1 sin upon Mallett levels were
downregulated
if she blocked the enzyme before it in
the pathway simple malate levels were
actually elevated and this this genetic
Legion is actually epistatic to this one
so if you make a double mutant these
sinop O'Malley levels are elevated so
that says two things one is it looks
like it could be a compound between this
block and this enzyme and this enzyme
that's responsible for leading to the
down regulation of phenol propanol tabal
ISM and also that this this cross talk
between glucosinolate synthesis and
found appropriately metabolism is
relevant in a wild-type context because
when you knock it out sinop O'Malley
levels actually go up so here is a
little bit of a schematic that did
survive the slide debacle here this
morning and so the idea here that is
that there are two types of good
simulates that are made in Rab drops and
the finding driver ones in which disobey
t3 a1 functions to form an album as an
intermediate and tryptophane derive Guk
assimilates in which city 3d1
functions again to for Maldek seems this
crosstalk appears to somehow affect
phenylpropanolamine and jung in by doing
a suppressor screen so she took the ref
five mutants remuda Jen eyes those and
looked for plants that were blue in the
m2 generation she found in a thing which
I a discovery which I still feel like
we're extremely lucky turns out to be
the suppressors turned out to be med
five one of the two subunits
so this crosstalk again now between two
pathways rather than within one pathway
is dependent upon mediator and she also
went on to show that the same
suppression would would be it was seen
when she crossed the Med five mutant
into the rf2 background which is the sub
eighty-three a one involved in Metheny
derived al vaccine synthesis so that
other blockage in the previous slide
that I mentioned this one here sub 79 B
2 and B 3 is the enzyme that converts
these these amino acids to the two there
L dog seems so again we block here we
get an accumulation of al vaccine it's
perceived by Med 5 and that somehow
impinges on phenylpropanolamine tables
so they try and determine how that
perturbation was enforced what was
responsible what was involved in that
crosstalk
jungnam did a rna-seq experiment and
it's somewhat complicated because she's
comparing four different lines so she's
comparing rf5 ref - and then ref live
with mediator knockout and ref - with a
mediator knockout so what she was
looking for rather than explaining it
through here I'd rather use these sort
of cartoons what she was looking for to
find genes involved in this crosstalk
was genes that were upregulated in both
ref 5 and ref - who's up regulation was
mediate or dependent so that when we
looked at breath 5 min 5 and ref -
mid-fight they went down or the other
way around genes that were down
regulated in the meat in these mutants
that went back up to normal in the
double and so those are represented by
53 genes at 18 genes which is a
manageable list and from
that she was able to identify two genes
that uh that were a particular interest
that met beckon spectacles criteria and
these are Celts repeat F box proteins
number 39 and number 50 so these are
upregulated in the glucosinolate mutants
and that upregulation is abolished when
we knock out med five same over here and
what do these things do these are
proteins are components of the process
that targets proteins for degradation by
the proteasome
in fact these KF d proteins are known to
interact with pal and target it for
degradation tells the first enzyme of
some appropriate pathway and I've
represented the proteasome was it with a
garbage disposal and I apologize if
there's anyone here who works on the
proteasome and I compared your work to
that anyway so in fact when she goes and
measures a pal activity in in these
various lines she does indeed see that
in the lines that are upregulated for K
the KF be proteins pal activity is down
and when we bring in the mediator
mutations that that the pal activity is
no longer reduced and in fact she's gone
on to knock out those KF b proteins and
to summarize a large large array of
different mutants if she takes the rest
v mutant and which has reduced levels of
Sinope O'Mally does it of course i've
been saying and knocks out these three
KF b proteins we get restoration of
appropriate metabolism so it seems that
out of that rna-seq experiment she was
actually able to identify the least one
protein that was or two proteins that
were responsible for this crosstalk okay
well I want to conclude with a final
story
about that goes back to the original
mutant that we identified that led us
into this mediator story because we
thought it would be a valuable reagent
to start I guess
dissecting mediator function in plants
so mediator is very well studied in
humans and in yeast and are a number of
mutants of mediator that are that that
show its relevance to a variety of
processes flowering time and whatnot
plant pathogen interactions in plants
but we certainly are just starting to
scrape the surface so a former graduate
student of mine did a another suppressor
screen as a way to start probing this
and so here's Columbia wild-type and the
ref for three mutant the dwarf and and
the very the three knockouts and so my
student did a suppressor screen looking
remute agonizing rough for three plants
and looking for plants that were now
blue under UV or big or both and the
idea behind it is to identify other
proteins that are required for this
dominant form of this med five subunit
to exert its action and so we so my
student identified this array of
suppressor mutants and handed this
project off to it to another grad
student and what she did was quantify
simple malate levels as well as lignin
but I'll just focus on this for today
but also sequence all of those
suppressors and identify the genes in
which they were defective so it's it's
um although each mutant has carries
about 200 EMS inducible mutations in the
open reading frames of the genome by
looking for taking a candidate gene
approach and
for genes that are mutated in common
basically an in silico ilysm test we
were easily able to identify the genes
that were that were responsible
so in these in these mutants we find a
sort of a spread of restoration of
phenol propanol metabolism the black
lines represent intragenic mutations in
med fine so if we turn this protein with
this one g2s mutation into a
constitutive a dominant break on the
pathway if we then knock it knock it out
we would expect to see a reversal of
that phenotype and indeed we do although
it's at various levels but the other
thing that came out of the screen was
mutants in three different mediator
subunits different one so this is med
two camed sixteen and mid twenty three
these are all in the tail of mediator
are thought to be with Med 5 and so
we're right now in the in the well you
see it's listed as submitted here we're
understanding how these different
mediator knockouts might affect gene
expression on their own and how they
affect gene expression in the context of
this rep for three mutation what I think
is quite interesting is that for example
these two this bill focus on this one
this suppressor restores by both the my
trails take that back both of these
suppressors one in mid to one in intro
genic mutation restore growth but not
sound Pro Konami tablet so we can we can
pull these apart again it's not the case
that if we just muck around with
mediator
we will abolish the function of rough
for three because here's a example of
two different
mediator Knockouts PST one men 25 and
med three and when we cross those into
the ref for three background we don't
get restoration of growth so again it's
not that these these results are
specific they're it's not just a case of
perturbing the tale of mediator that
restores the flocks breath for three
function okay when you went on to do an
RNA seek experiment and found then I
guess a continuing theme in that in ref
four three this what one of the same kfb
proteins involved in pal degradation is
dramatically up regulated and in her
suppressors there they are restored to
near to near normal suggesting that this
pal degradation is again in this context
responsible for the phenotypes that we
see in this view so I can just wrap up
now and say well so here's our here are
our models then so looking at the
glucosinolate example we have a cross
talk between two pathways that is
mediator dependent where if we block
phenyl scintillate synthesis and that
leads to the accumulation of these al
vaccines
these are perceived somehow by med
5-week and we lead to up regulation of
these kfb proteins which target pal for
degradation and therefore we reduce the
downstream components of this pathway in
the case of anthocyanins we think
there's a similar thing going on where
when we block at 5h there's a buildup of
an upstream metabolite that is perceived
by med 5 or directly or indirectly that
also turns on kfb decreases pal and in a
Cell probably in a cell type-specific
way
knocks down an assignment synthesis with
rf8 it's a little bit more complicated
we do know that kfb gene expression is
chanced in this in this that very dwarf
mutant that we had at c3 prime age
perhaps again because of a buildup of
some metabolite but there are there's
another huge set of changes in gene
expression that lead to dwarfing that
are med five dependence so it's a more
complicated story and in the case of ref
four three we have in fact a mutant form
of this Med 5 protein that has the
ability to constitutively turn on this
kfb protein leading to pala beg relation
and an impact on phenol program so I
hope I've convinced you that mediator is
involved in phenol provide homeostasis
we were we would desperately like to
know what it's perceiving and how its
perceiving it and we have efforts going
on in the lab to try and figure that out
the in that first example the dwarfing
that we've seen in low lignin clamps can
be suppressed genetically we always
thought it was a sort of a mechanical
problem to do with water transport but
there's it's much more complicated than
that involving a mediator and AD has
aberrations in gene expression this kfp
net mediated degradation of pal
seems to be a common mechanism for
regulating this pathway previous to that
and and and I really shouldn't end this
talk without mentioning that this was
this whole this whole idea was first
identified by CJ Liu at Brookhaven and
without without that knowledge that he
contributed to the literature we still
wouldn't understand what was going on
this seems so before that we really
thought that it was feedback from
cinemate the product of the enzyme so
this is a really important new paradigm
I think and I would also say that I
mentioned it in passing we have these
h.length implants we've got g ligaments
forget s ligaments these
these plants with modified lignans are I
think theory going to be could be
valuable for biorefinery in this
industry if that ever really gets going
because it's taking a important run
abundant product in the plant cell wall
and turning it into something with more
defined characteristics and then thereby
could be more easily converted to
downstream products of value and with
that I guess I would like to thank
people who did the work
Nicky Anderson and Nick Bono it's Nick
Bono it's worked on all the rough 8
suppression stuff Nick and Nick together
on the anthocyanin project jeongnam on
the gooks inlay project and Whitney and
Jake on the rep for three suppressor
project and also my collaborators John
did the new key who did the NMR and CJ
and Brian delts for help with the
sequencing and suppressor analysis and
with that I will say thank you very much
for your attention in the invitation
[Applause]
yeah
so I have a question about fit work to
work between the so it might be slightly
different angle from this matter but
there's a music school division
variances which can seriously over it's
justa little against it and that a lot
of religion may be written to work and
somehow I just think there is a link
between just to be good so it's like I
said it's also from any line io signa
right so is there any to think micro but
the democratic you over experienced in
Pacifica practically matters in distance
because all people simply argue that if
you have a lot of different mechanisms
we look like overexpression so I guess
then the energy distribution of the plan
would be more viable differences and of
course submit so I think we need another
one of these efficient of people that
are all building okay so there's a
there's a lot rolled up into that
classic ah so let me let me tell you
what little I know about it
so first of all yes there's growth
defense trade-offs quantitatively lignin
is vastly more abundant than than si so
whatever we're doing with lignin
although it could add to si
I don't think how much si appliance
makes is really closely tied to lignin
abundance I would also say that my other
my one of my other grad students will be
very happy to hear the us as question
because I didn't have time to talk about
it today but with when once when he had
basically completed her rep for three
suppressor analysis
my other student Candide asked whether
the CD k-8 kinase module which is known
to have
repressive effects on transcription
could be involved in the phenotypes that
we see in the rough 4-3 mutant so she
showed that it was that knocking out see
bk8
reverses dwarfism but has no effect on
sunup Rokinon metabolism and looking at
her transcriptome data she saw that sa
synthesis conjugation and response genes
were all up regulated so she said all
it's it's let's test the hypothesis that
si is involved in the dwarfing and so
she knocked it out with by crossing in
cid to mutation and found that sid -
does not it reduces si si si
accumulation is expected but it had no
effect on growth of this mutant so I
can't say it doesn't contribute at all
but there are other factors that are
more important in that particular case I
guess yeah just about the mediator that
target regulation for like responsive
doing so many different thing
are they like falls out of genus
regulated you see related pathways it
could be like related like you're
decreasing the width of them that you
want to take James like that it's just
like it's regulating all types of things
well certainly there's many different
pathways that are that are perturbed
when you knock of different mediator
subunits I mean Keogh analysis will
always tell you that right no matter
what set of genes you look at
practically but with regard with regard
to but the glucosinolate crosstalk I'm
still of two minds about that that whole
story and I we've been trying to
actually ask the question is this
as you sort of framed it I don't think I
did but I think it's reasonable that you
did that you would want to have
crosstalk to coordinate the two pathways
you know there might be some situation
where you want to use some appropriate
eyes for defense and other times when
you want to use Google Sites okay that's
that's a good model or is it kind of a
pharmacological effect so we know we can
do a chemical biology experiment and we
can add compounds exogenous ly to yeast
or seedlings or whatever and see an
effect on a pathway on growth something
like that
so is this crosstalk something that
operates like that
just so happens that these al doc scenes
have this effect or or are they is this
cross a truly important for biology
I would I would think that if such a
pharmacological effect exists it it must
exist sort of as a precursor to the
evolution of important important
coordination between pathways if you if
you know it there's got to be something
for evolution to work on so until there
is something like that I don't know how
you sieve all
pardon that's or teleology such an such
a crosstalk so I'm I'm reluctant to say
that this is really metabolic
coordination although it could be that
means I'm not sure that answers your
question
little bit yeah so Louis regards FIFA
evidence that there was such specific
variations as you're seeing for example
around restitution it's not not slimming
policies compared to the example cells
but maybe one-time work UV filter cell
type specialization within lonely and
see different interactions or degrees of
Expressionism as I would thought this
idea that spinkle it's pronounced
satellites different generations right
so but at the same time we have that we
have the
ask whether that's coming about because
of as a result of what mediator is doing
or whether it's coming about because of
where just by happenstance there is an
overlap between books and later found
propanol metabolism did you see any
predominant expression with it it sounds
like of of what we don't have that
information it's not we don't see it at
very high levels and it's actually been
a big pain to do the biochemistry you
have to actually be looking at to go
back to cell cultures meristematic cells
seem to be where it's expressed most
highly but we're actually trying to get
at this question by installing the al
Doc seem synthesize the enzymes of 79 in
non glucosinolate producing plants to
ask do you see the same impact on film
program metabolism because that would
argue that it is a pharmacological
effect perhaps so very question Gino is
anticipating regulation I thought for
the mediator uh I don't know um if you
really see very little interesting
things when you look at expression
analysis of a mediator complex and maybe
that's because you know it's required
for most regulated gene expression and
so it has to be everywhere again you do
see it as some of the subunits up in
their stems and whether that reflects
particular role for those subunits or
just higher requirements for
transcription in those cells I don't
know
okay for the question space would be
disgusting a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu